ش 1
وصلنا إلى هنا على شاطئ الجو
مكان يسمى مورو دو بادري
وأين نجد هنا حوتًا
الهائل
وانظر هنا
فريقنا كبير جدا
سكرتير البلدية للبيئة
يحاول الوصول إلى الفضاء
من الصعب جدا هنا الطيور
من الفريسة في الواقع هم الذين لا يفعلون ذلك
لفتوا انتباهنا
أعتقد أن الملك أعطت موافقًا بالفعل
الكثير من المال الكثير من الأيام هنا
الناس كبيرة جدا
وأنا بالفعل في أسفل أنا ألصق نفسي في كل مكان
هنا في وسط توري يا إلهي
الحرص على أن تكون وحيدا
يا له من شيء عظيم مجرد إلقاء نظرة عليه
لديك فكرة عن حجم الحيوان
ماذا فعلت للهائلة
مرحباً بالجميع هذا هو الحوت الذي جنح
هنا في سوري
وعلى شاطئ أرارونا لكني تخيلت
التي كانت على الشاطئ حتى في الداخل
مع ذلك هي ذاهبة إلى الداخل للحب
كبير تمكن من إحضاره جره هنا
في عمق الأدغال
طول زيت الحذاء
ما أخبارك
و أوتش
هو حوت القرش و